[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone what's up welcome to
simulation we are now sitting down with
dr. Eduardo Torres Hara hello hello
thank you for coming on the show my
pleasure thank you for having me
yes we're so excited especially because
sensitive robotics right it's so
important to talk about it is everyone
and their mothers talking about computer
vision correct but not enough people are
talking about this tactical sensing and
in the sensitivity that's associated
with it we're gonna unpack this in so
much detail I'm really excited to do so
let's give a little bit of background so
Eduardo is a PhD from in AI and robotics
from MIT he then works with the MIT AI
lab for 10 years then he professed at
Worcester Polytechnic Institute for five
years and then was at the Stanford
Research Institute for three years as
well as a senior research engineer and
so then he's now at a rave Oh also as a
senior scientist for a year working on
some 3d printing in airplanes bicycles
and also I'm the kind of the founder of
this theory of sensitive robotics and so
ok let's maybe let's go back to the
early days this MIT days when you're
first getting into AI and robotics what
drew you to the field so you know I
always you know like any kid that
fascinated by science fiction right so
you see these robots doing these cool
things and you know being capable though
that there's amazing things and so I was
in Ecuador where I did my undergrad and
where I'm originally from so I proposed
first like let's do a robot as my thesis
and the emphasis was more into
telecommunications signal processing and
remember this is the end of the nightly
AV sorry so it's like there were no much
technology
available to us through the
experimentation but you know they let me
play as a TC so I build my robot with
good get step motors from all different
places and we put it together and at
that time artificial intelligence was
having a big conversation about what is
the best way to do it naturally normally
was done like as a top-down approach
there is a brain and the body will just
execute what the brain is telling you
brother Brooks at that time was living a
different way to do it which was a
bottom-up approach so we have if we have
a body then we can create intelligence
by using the sensing and using the body
as part of this process and so it was
very controversial because he was taking
a very extreme position like no planning
at all what the other people was if you
don't have any planning there's no
possible to do it and so that
conversation brought a lot of light of
like you can't you don't only need to do
it one way but the other way it's very
useful then many things came out of this
Alice's claim came out of this like you
know the profs that went to different
planets were smaller with more limited
computational capabilities and simple
tasks as opposed to did large robots
that we're supposed to send before which
are very big too heavy even to put into
the rockets and send it to the other
planet until I start reading those 10
papers like in a quadrant like this is
fascinating you can do very simple
robots at that time one of the
inspirations for all groups were insects
so the robots were very simple and very
capable so we always were saying that
you know you have this big robot with
computer vision and it will take a few
minutes to take every step because it
was making a model of everything doing
the calculation and being capable of
moving but the ants will are this small
they have all the capital they need and
they can survive not only walk and do
all these things so the idea was to do
action more directly between the sensors
and actuator and an actuation and
modulate that interaction and so I was
like this is fascinating I want to do
that and so it was ideal for us we'll
have a small robot very simple
computation and we built you know we
call it the first robot and a quarter
I'm not sure that was true it made it to
national television I was like I like
this and so I didn't know in English at
that time so I was like okay I'm gonna
study the language and I start applying
to schools and I applied to MIT because
rod Brooks was there like I had to work
with this guy Brooks and say I apply
after some years of studying English
what happened is that all these schools
reject me but MIT MIT actually gave me a
fellowship and it was given by rod
Brooks I will work directly with brother
Brooks and working in like humanoids
already so it was all fascinating dream
comes I came that's how we call you know
research started oh yeah yeah and then
you know then the whole story that they
start with small projects human oh it's
a navigation and at that time we let's
go back to the ant quick and then we'll
Delaware yeah okay yeah this is this is
interesting you bring up this comparison
we've always thought that this robot
that can sense everything needs to be
large but when you look at just the
smallest creature of like an ant and
also I remember I was learning about
this in terms of neuronal computing as
well as in the human the human brain you
don't need anywhere near as much as this
to be able to figure things out
for example the fly only has like less
than 50 neurons very small amount of
neurons but it can sense its environment
and buzz around and fly around and land
and and and engage with environment with
so little neurons versus our 86 billion
so the same thing with the ant the ant
is so small and then how does the ant
that small be able to perceive its
environment and survive in its
environment but survive and then how do
we take the perception system
the tactical sensing of robots and bring
it to that small size right right so you
know that that was the inspiration of
much of this work and what this big
conversation addresses during the abies
mainly which is ok why this very small
bodies can do all these things and we're
building this huge thing with all these
computation
and what mainly like as was understood
is that there's a direct connection
between the sensing and actuation
and the neurons and all the neurological
system was modulating the interaction as
opposed to try to create a model of
everything and you say that again so
it's just modulation modulating the
interaction between the actuation and
the sentencing instead of approach the
problem as we scientists we're
approaching which was let's model
everything around because as engineers
and scientists we're going to have a
model and we can operate that model and
say we apply this force here the robot
will go there and if we know that
there's an obstacle there we will go
around and so supposed to go in that
direction so because I just sensing
modulation is that more than in the near
the the local areas of the body sensing
and modulation versus you're saying
making a whole entire diagram and
explanation of what's going on every
moment of what's happening and then
acting on that right so there was a lot
of evidence sound like we humans don't
have a full model everything of
everything that's happening there's some
experiments where you know they ask you
to assemble Legos where they show you
the model here and you had to put
together the same thing here but as you
go back and for the out 30 model and
you'll notice and it's not because we're
not smart it's just like that's how we
work we just focus on things and so we
don't need all that information I love
other videos you see the basketball the
counter amount of times the basketball
gets passed by the team in white
and then the gorilla runs through the
wat and you're not looking at the
gorilla and they show it to you
afterward exactly this is interesting to
them we do it when you brought up with
the lair yeah yeah yeah there are
experiments like no in psychology and
people who study all these areas in
neuroscience which have shown that we
don't have a model of everything but
still we are way more Dexter's than the
robots that will have a model of
everything so it's almost as though when
we look at the one version of the Legos
then we see okay I have to put the long
green rectangle piece on this part okay
move over to that part and moving the
green rectangle piece I've lost this
model out of my head almost serene
global amount the global the one with
mall who's only the green part so when I
look back and I see the green still
there I'm like yes but then you might
have added a blue one to the corner over
here and I don't Renault the hell right
yeah correct and so and then other
things you know that came out or they're
exploited now is that no everything has
to go to the brain right so our model is
very hierarchical we have a hierarchy of
only in the nervous system so the brain
has only takes care of like higher level
functions as we go down and we taught
you know cerebellum and spinal cord and
all this part all of them do local
computation and so our reflexes only go
to the spinal cord and so we modulate
that
oh it's believed that we modulate that
type of reflection as opposed to
according to plan every motion that we
do in robotics for example or
manipulation when you want to move do
some tasks like moving your glass and
bring it over here there will be a plan
or while the approaches is this will be
a plan to get there gravity the glass
bring it to you but everything is known
there's some additional work and say
well if we are if we add some if the
glass is moved right yeah but now you
know we can say okay nowadays we have a
better perception so we have cameras we
have lasers we can say yes you can
compensate for things but the approach
itself is like we
this big plan we have this model of
everything the other alternative is like
well we can have a rough approximation
of things and use these sensors as we
need it so visually you know it was a
good idea well the glasses over there I
can try to use my hand to go in that
direction the opposite will be but had
no idea then I will have to explore all
the table to find out where the glasses
but but when you get there there are
sensors that are more important so
tactile feedback turns out any one of
them and that is one focus of my
research because we try to do many
things with computer vision and too much
with computer vision because what
happens many things like there's the
sayings like we believe that we think
that we know how we think every time
that we do this is a problem yeah no we
think that way and we say that and you
know we believe we know the way that we
think exactly but we pretty much know
less than what we do know both of these
things has been debated nothing the
cases happen is like we believed it was
going to work that way but that as we
explore more research more terms of
didn't it was completely yeah a
different approach it simpler or things
like that and so that is that is a
typical flow that we as researchers run
into in this field and so one of you
know getting back to this title sensing
was like well so when we get to do
manipulation should we still keep
focusing on having a plan and moving the
robot very precisely or she will try to
do something else or you know like
nowadays there's a lot of hype in AI and
sometimes you know I find the I hear
this assertion is like well you know if
you have the AI the computer vision will
figure out everything will have a model
and then we will just use existent arm
like we're industrial arm and the
inertial arm is very precise so it will
get where we tell them to go and the
things will be solved and that was the
thinking early on in AI as well but what
is very important is that that doesn't
completely work because if you don't
into if you don't include the
interaction of the body or you don't
even consider that things won't work and
that's why we see robots that are you
know very fast and very precise at
motion but when you change something in
the environment they can no adapt and
tasks as simple as like no again we're
going to get to this I've just yeah I
get some water and drinking a lot of
other sensors besides the the division
were involved yeah so computer vision
most likely was telling me and this in
this case human vision is telling me
okay that's where I should go but I
don't need the information computer
vision to grab it yeah once I get there
yeah and this breaks many of the
assumptions yeah we I that means that if
I don't need to be very precise then my
my arm can be a lot softer and when the
arms a lot softer now I can make contact
with things without damaging or without
knocking them all right there's a you
know there's a specific reason why
precise arms have to be stiff if you try
to do this with a precise iron a robotic
arm most likely will knock it over or
you had to be very slowed together yeah
humans are really good at what I call
come in with an interaction with the
world so we can do this you can sitting
here I'm doing all this test yeah
because my sensors are telling me you
are stable there's no enough stress to
break you so my legs are in a flat
surface so it has been the force has
been distributed I was getting back to
the example of like when I get some
water when they actually drinking a lot
of your tactile sensing is actually
helping you yes and the example I used
to describe some of the reasons why they
are so important first one is that the
cup meets the lips right so that you
don't spill that so that means that you
don't have to
precise but that's a really good point
right so you have to be precise because
I can keep moving until I make contact
yes but we are soft so we can make
contact without damaging but even more
important when you start drinking it you
need to have the feedback to say the
water is inside and you can close your
lips according to what you mean you know
an example to prove the prove this is
that when you have never came when you
go to the dentist and you don't feel
your peril your mouth when you try to
drink water and if you went to that
example ever what happens you pour the
water and just like oh you have a lot of
that you have to concentrate a lot to
try to do these simple test that's
drinking yeah so because your senses are
because your sensors are gone and so you
don't know what's happening and so in
your repulsion and the vision doesn't
even matter that so many of you focus
because you don't have the sensing
that's important right even if you use
your whole human brain and try to say uh
where's the water
you don't know because you don't have
the sensing this is so important that
you know there's some humans that have
have lost the capability of tactile
sensing yeah usually from the neck down
I'm sorry there's one from the neck down
and one from half the face I believe the
one from half the face need to be
retrained for many hours to actually be
able to eat yeah using only the position
of the hand and computer vision just so
complicated yeah
the other person has a lot of problems
with walking because that information is
you know you tactile sensing and your
skin which is kind of interesting right
now if you think back to the well you
know even a cell can can sense what
surrounded the the limits of the cell
and that should be one of the first
sensors need to interact in the real
world and we are building robots without
that capability which in some cases make
sense right so you want a crane that's
very strong just gonna move for anything
from one side to the other is okay a
person can go and put the hooks where
you need it and then the crane can do it
that's one type of task but if we went
dexterity and interacting with the world
then that approach
causing
and now as we can try to emulate more
what we humans have and do the tests in
a different way so this is the premise
of your research the research ok and so
I can show you a video you want that
let's do it and then give us a little
prep a little bit of history right
before that the research was done at MIT
with a lot of them I see with brother
Brooks correct brought a book nod Brooks
correct and then this was in 2000 I
wished I hope 2004 I think was 2004 ok
and then it ended around 2000 and MIT
and then they're out 2008 that's an
Anglican but then I continued as a
professor as a professor right yeah ok
yeah let's do it let's do it yeah show
us
yes so before I play it let me just give
you a background so will you see there
is a robot that I call a Brera so robot
is means human worker in check I think
and a rare look means wait and working
with vanish we robot yes means worker
and check yes okay yeah holy cow okay
and operator operator operator you know
similar to somewhere over and the idea
is that this robot captures some of the
hardware in the sensing and the
architecture that we have humans have so
I was inspiring humans yeah and well
you'll see they're a little bit like a
dark right there is a person in front of
the robot is going to move a ceramic cap
you see that indeed table there's no
fixtures as most of the industrial
robots have for their part yeah and also
there's no a specific marker on the
table where we're gonna put the cap so
there's more surrender to humans now
what will happen if we we have
industrial robot doing this we will have
need to model where exactly the cap is
and move very careful or very fast but
to the exact position without colliding
with the cap yeah and then closing it
specifically to the dimensions of the
cap and then moving it to the different
position here the robot is going to
behave more like a human at the
beginning is going to look at the motion
of the cap I'm going to make the robot
blind and purpose to show the power of
the tactile sensing after showing the
motion and so the robot now is gonna
explore by touching the chair yeah I'm
feeling its way around so you don't need
a model of the cap because as feeling
goes the palpation goes around and you
you understand what's happening with the
cap and you can position the right place
and it does build a model it does in
this case we use a very simplified model
okay but as we progress we can build
more complex maybe in it in in the plane
in a three dimensional plane as it
touches does it make markings right when
we will say we've known learning in the
three-dimensional space we're learning
in this sensing space in the sensing to
understand more directly what's
happening and since there's a different
map on the sensors on that exactly okay
and then why does that happen
there's becomes but there are more
important tests that are overlooked in
more traditional approach when actually
lifting the way is done is usually you
close the robot to a given position
because you have pre calculated or
experimented to see what's the minimum
force that you need these are what
actually sense that you are getting to
the point and when you move around if is
feeling that it's not know I flip in a
way haha and it keeps us stable grasp
and more important now it's moving right
so when they're gonna bring it back what
happens in the normal robot is you take
the glass here's the surface we're gonna
put it it's coming here and someone has
told you subtly what's the fact and you
just put it there and when you're very
close you should let it go so basically
you know if all over the surface because
there's no tactical right that's why
many times we have a fixture with this
pallet to avoid breaking something like
this uh-huh
if we're cutting something like this
this robot on the other hand when it
comes back actually touches as we humans
do the surface it feels we tactile
feedback that I have support for the
other slippage and I let it got it got
it so you will see that in the video so
so the person is shaking the cap in
front the robot is looking at closing
the eyes right now and the fingers are
very soft so they're not precise are
soft and sensitive oh wow and even fit
even fling like that oh so cool so if
you compare where Trish and robot a
robot is very stiff to avoid those
motions but here now is lifting it
moving it back and when it makes contact
he feels that now they're safe contact
now let go what is interesting is that I
don't have to change the algorithm for a
set of objects as long as the object is
sticking out the robot is so interested
you know it's generalizable as
understand and now like it but it
probably won't be able to with that
style of hand it probably can't pick up
something as small as maybe an eraser or
a couple grains of rice or something
swell our bond may tell you that that's
not correct we actually can do it and
I'll show you that's me okay okay small
but you bring a very important point so
that kind of a manipulation that you saw
right now is what's called whole-body
grasp so you have the object and you use
your fingers as arms and you embrace the
object yes that's called what it grabs
body grabs right
okay now what you mentioned using the
fingertips we humans are very
distressing the finger games and we call
this percise manipulation and you know
when you hear precise you imagine that
the robot needs to be more precise for
many reasons right now you are dealing
with the smaller dimensions so if you
try to grab something and smaller that
will be very difficult so we can usually
the approach is like let's do something
that's a bit more precise so this type
of approach will be right away as trial
and that's not going to work but we have
proved the opposite that this approach
using more sensing that then precision
is better because we can actually deal
with that and that's how in theory we
believe humans do it so let me jump into
that let's do it
let me find the video right here and I'm
going to show you in two parts I need to
steal you first the context
Ron isn't this amazing sensitive
robotics is the future so this is the
hand you saw yeah by the way you know
the reason for does that shape of the
sensors because human inspire is
inspired in the ridges of attacks on the
human finger let's explain this first
villain when we were when we were first
hanging out that you gave me the
explanation I was I was literally
leaning against the wall we're talking
and you were like you know the reason
why you're so sorry right now and stay
there yeah yeah explanation of that and
then we walk in to welcome to walk in
here this hand was made with traditional
engineering so parts were made with
aluminum and machine with precision well
they wrote the fingers were done so that
their imprecise but soft
first thing south because when I make
contact a very important thing most
robots can't do that three fingers this
one has three three fingers yeah here is
interesting it's made just like the
except there if two two two of these
yeah you know arguable probably we need
more depending India needed but this was
you know it's it in engineering is a
trade-off right it's like if I make it
too complex I never get to test actually
wired tested so in these two phalanges
the phalanges are a couple so when I
close it always doing this yeah in this
robot the fallacies are uncoupled be
more like the human one but only two we
have three now this was not imprecisely
with 3d printing so precision is no
something that important like was
important in this hand it was like make
it very sensitive so the fingers again
are soft the jointer soft and the
sensors would reduce on side what is the
material made of silicon rubber it's
silken Robert yes okay and then we'll
explain what we're doing yes so what
happens here is like this was a be be
paying for this research evv is a large
company
together with NASA and some other
sponsor I forgot and when they came to
us said well 80% of all the tasks that
we are requested to do with our robots
we cannot do it can you help us to solve
it and this was the solution
clearly orthogonal to traditional
manipulation I mentioned that because
later
DARPA came and said well we want you to
deal with something that's very complex
which is handling the VY complex' pieces
that you used to play go play go the the
yeah and they call it Chinese chess yes
yeah so the one that is now the world
champion is lost all right all right so
those are very slippery pieces like you
be touching inside they sleep away to
the point of the professional players to
give like girly to have really good
control to put the fingers like this
yeah because it's a very slippery piece
is the right yeah a little flat yeah so
these robots gonna do that that does
usually so complicated people use
suction caps and they forget about this
forget a problem simplify by doing that
and manipulation in in the in industry
has gone that way it's like let's put
just suction caps on that so that's no
is the case so let me show you this
first there was computer vision that
position the arm roughly over the board
mm-hmm and those fingers no I see what's
doing that's let's go down yeah see how
it's gonna act more like humans so it's
touching one side shifting it over use
your finger to get under to scoop it and
leaving it awesome remember this is
precision manipulation because now we're
talking about millimeters precision done
with no precision done with sensing
because I sense the touch
I sent under this is the eraser example
that I was bringing up earlier you now
you that's basically the same size an
eraser on the end of a pencil about the
same size as a real piece right yeah you
know there's a limitation on that
explain what's the limitation because if
the piece becomes a smaller it's
difficult to manipulate so that's why
you know we sometimes a stick in with
our fingers to the right that's why I'm
it right
but here look at that so I'll show you
the same thing you saw in fast with a
fast camera with so the robots coming
down pay attention to this finger this
finger is given in a little bit so
that's very important because these
fingers are soft if this robot was rigid
like normal technology is when we're
using robot you will have either brake
broke the the fingertip of the robot
leave a really big mark on the table it
has to be like that silicon softness
this one is the second level of softness
is now only the sensor is the softness
on the fingers that's why we humans can
do this with no problem no because of
the skin that because of the of the
muscles and the tendons that we have
after so this is easy we don't break it
yeah the same thing yeah now that we did
this let me go to the next slide and
when I tried to move the finger on this
moment my right toe where's the left so
I can actually grab it but what happens
if I only do that then the it moves a
little bit but get stopped by the board
which is on your way aha what do we do
then we compensate with the wrist and so
when you compensate with the wrist the
tactile sensors itself is helping you to
do that task so we use sensitivity to
touch it compliance on the fingers and
week we're capable do this so we have
replaced precision with sensitivity it
turns out that that opens a lot of
possibilities for this approach I was
going to explain first this answers
before we jump into the intro walking
okay should we go there to the whistling
how these sensors work oh yeah I wanna
see a walking robot with this technology
let's explain the sensing first yes yes
which which I've started to call the
opposite octopus correct like suction
cuppy invert it right yeah so let me
explain with this picture here so this
is a sectional cut of the skin yeah
we're gonna focus on this side that it
has
you know here mm-hmm and if there's not
a great assume in but Naevia is that
these are the sensors that detect shear
forces they are the one to detect normal
forces we as electrical engineers have
built many versions of this and we have
done amazing things however when you put
in a robot many times they don't work
because what for us turns out to be very
important is that this is the rage and
the fingertip yeah
and that geometry has the property that
is prone to make contact and each to the
one and that is why the system is so
good in your fingertips versus paint in
this flat it would be a lot more
difficult so a lot of people design
sensors put it under or put we expose
directly to the surface but there's no
there's a lot of theory that you can
explain you know like why they don't
work but that's yeah let me let's give
the example of when we were hanging out
when you taught me that I was I was
standing and leaning against the wall
when we were talking and then you told
me that you know the reason why you're
you're able to do this and talk right
now is because you have the sensitivity
perception system your tactile feedback
from the wall you know that once you hit
the wall that that is going to support
you and that you're supporting that's
why you can lose a little bit of balance
or power on your leg and stuff like that
and then further then you explain to me
that the reason why we can feel like the
wall in its full all of its little bumps
and ridges and everything is because of
our the fingerprint all of the little
ridges on the fingerprint cuz if you if
at home if you look at your fingerprint
you see that it's kind of like this big
this big Hingham right but every single
one of those little ridges as you go to
as the center of your fingers over the
ridge and so then that is what enables
you to feel these bigger directionality
and this pressure yes yeah well versus
if it was flat if there were no ridges
it would be a lot more difficult to do
anything and that's why yeah and that
you know so inspiring that we
create those bubbles and those bubbles
basically do the same thing biologically
inspired around I really enjoy that we
just had Arvind Gupta from India on the
show and we'd love biological
inspiration the whole world can be
programmed with the code of biology in a
way that's more sustainable and in this
case is more innovative we're able to
get there faster because we leverage
what we already know Wow yeah
or another way to say it too is like you
know there's a system that really works
that's out there in many different
environments
why don't we take a look at that and
there's usually there's many things that
you know we came out with and so turns
out that I start with manipulation we
were able to solve a lot of different
climbing more complex problems just a
lot of videos that shows everyone every
one of details but turns out that's very
useful in other areas so walking robots
one of them so let me jump into one of
them thanks to you so when will we do
the opposite octopus you want to do that
you mean you want to see the sensor let
Charice - yeah sure we do that first
then we'll do the walking okay let's do
that
so I think people are interested in it
yeah all right so that's the sensor it
is a is a semiosphere
in birthday semi-sphere right let you
know how the semiosphere yep half this
period semiosphere yep and then there's
a dip right know that deep is what
happens when I'm applying the force and
when applying this force yeah when we
apply a force we deform the structure
and we can detect it we can detect a
deformation interesting I use different
technologies to detect a deformation so
then the sensor is located in the middle
like so when it gets pushed down the
sensor sees that it's being - okay
they'll give you an estimation of the
force but the only techni normal force
but also the lateral forces so the load
can come from the side and it'll be
pushed down towards this side and then
horizontal displacement like you're
saying horizontal versus vertical
displacement and then what would is so
this is again the silicon but then what
is the sensor oh there are many ways to
do it
you have displacement you know and
they're like a lot of patterns are there
what's what's the sensor in this case
that you see specifically is a magnetic
version of magnetic yes oh there's the
Hall effect that is detecting the energy
of a magnet oh but ha there are many
other ways that was the first one that
you know I did it have you moved on
something better yes
what are these on the wraps oh it's okay
okay we have many versions than that
yeah so interesting because there's
there's so many different ways to make
the semi spheres with a sensor and the
displacement so what's gonna be the one
that ends up being a best correct yes
that's that is no how we've tagged us
yeah so now that we had that you know we
create models within mathematical models
of this and we have simulations now let
me show you something that's a little
bit more and you guys get how and how
it's like the opposite of the octopus
because it's like the octopus has all
those you know suction cups I can put
like you say pairs of two here but
they're they're inverted they're they're
not the semi-sphere outward they're
inward on the semi sphere and so this is
exactly the opposite it's the opposite
octopi think those comes yes the mirror
version they had the mirror version
opposite octopus so you know the working
is a complex problem oh wow there they
are right on the feet so turns out that
you know we use a lot of vor information
we are the particular information that
you know we have in the inner ear we
have information about the rotation or
acceleration so we could not walk if we
didn't have if we lost people who have
done it have a lot you know they have to
be retrained and something can no walk
right because of that if you actually
get to lose that information a lot of
people have problems with that sense
with losing sensitivity indeed for many
reasons and that's what we don't even
think twice about when I'm walking I put
my heel and my front of my foot down and
I know stable I move next leg we don't
think too much about that right
right so there's a lot like we think
about well we're gonna send exactly
there's a lot of research on like you
know like can we use the tactile
feedback on the feet do the walking
yeah instead of trying to use or
combined with the VOR information so we
built this robot that is a cat
simulation but should a cat sorry
model but soon and show you the actual
robot arms very similar and we put
tactile feedback on defeat because you
know you can walk blindly right you
don't need any information information
if the land isn't if you're not next to
a cliff correct correct correct correct
but you know even if you're in stairs
you know if you know as you can touch it
and you can start filling these out so
you do stairs yeah so in general you
know computer vision is very helpful for
predicting what's in front but then when
you are doing you are to act and when
you are with the body in the middle you
need to understand where your body is or
how its interacting with the external
world and the way to do it is in this
case we tactile feedback so that you
know I call this even contact robotics
or things like that so most of the
robotics that you see outside like you
know driving cars or helicopters or any
of those are like no contact robotics
right so a car you sure there's contact
with the floor but that's all they do
you are no trying to make contact with
anything you're trying to avoid it same
for the flying robots and things like
that and when you call that I call it
[ __ ] robot oh they're the flying
robot whatever you call it was the
contact robot yeah but they're the
opposite they don't want to make exactly
so I don't know but I call this contact
robotics which is it has an interest
with other type of robots like gosh
which don't make eye contact okay or you
know like a helicopter when I make
contact when you do landing but you we
don't pay attention much to that it's
like okay that's that difficult test
yeah if you see a bird flying that's an
important part for them right so they
can go and like land on a branch and no
problem right
so and I'll talk a little bit about it
okay so this isn't working and so I'll
just gonna show you you know this is the
actual robot you can see that it looks
very similar to the to the CAD model
mm-hmm
my students were like like creative
enough to actually paint the same color
and everything and so let me show you a
couple of videos about that this one on
that so this is the kind of reaction
that you can have when you have a robot
with sensitive feet so there as you move
you see that dot is showing what's the
center of pressure of the robot as we
move let's let's have rocky let's have
Ronnie zoom in on the top or at corner
arrows okay yep all right thank you for
the side you see the center of pressure
and see you see the robot tube use one
lateral I'm well in front and the
student here is moving it with their
hand just to show how the robot to react
you can play it okay so you see the
robot move to the left the center
pressure moves as the person so we can
estimate where's the main position and
what part of the and what was divorcing
in all the area of the foods so that's
important for us to keep a stability so
let's go to the next video okay the one
top right corner
you can and then what is happening there
is my student there is putting a book
under the sensors and you see the robot
is actually reacting it is to the book
to the block along then that you know if
we show that we have sensitivity to that
and so the first coordinated test they
did it but you know what should be the
last one last video on the bottom of the
page one week air chance thank you so
that one is the robot is standing on its
own but as opposed to just like locking
the legs and trying you know like a like
a piece of furniture is actually feeling
the distribution with forces on the feet
and yeah fusing so actually can this get
it stabilized there's more like a baby
trying to stand up for the first time
yeah and so as you know the advantage is
that new ones you get this then you can
deal with any kind of surfaces and
though you have seen many of the working
robots they walk in flat surfaces
because this is to predict where you're
gonna stand there's something thumbs
down by Boston Dynamics that is that
they don't need that speaking of which
we were trying to get you guys onto the
show when we were a boss we're coming
back for you coming back and we'll get
you on the show so let me tell you what
I students miss Tilly who build this now
works for Boston Dynamics so he actually
brought this robot to show them and he
was hired it's so funny how they just
have they just grabbed talent so you
know that's I mean this he did a
mechanical part the work you see here is
like the advanced version with a student
who is just up show up before was the
one doing it that's you know they have
that talent with them Wow so that do you
know to let me show you one more example
how since earth sensitive robotics
changed things
we have cubed let's focus on one for now
yeah cuz we still want to run you
through a bunch of our colleague
questions
let me show this light when I show in
sequence a few of them so these are
flying robot I mean these are flying
creatures so they're really good at
manipulating the air yeah flying we can
think as manipulated the air for that we
need to feel it and since you're doing
that motion is very important because we
focus on that right we believe that okay
we need the flapping and it's very
important you know the flapping that is
the gliding through the wind - and the
flap and this robot for example our
flappers right this is done by faster
and this I don't know was paid by DARPA
thank you
and it's you know it's a hummingbird who
can stay in place if you see what
happened on the the anatomy of these
animals you know you see your hands and
you see the bat it's very similar you
just have the form fingers it's just the
form fingers right so we have exactly
the same Anatomy how do we really flying
now
yeah so the back one more time yeah this
is so interesting yeah it's very like
revealing right it's exactly the same
bonds you know you can see even for
swimming will be the same argument
because the turtles have the same thing
so let's go to the fly and so turns out
that there's a classification of the
feathers and this one here called Philip
plume is on the vase when you connect to
the bomb and so the feathers as they
move you can understand how they're
moving and that gives you information
about your interaction with the error so
you have the acting of your fingers
interacting with it so instead of the
tactile feedback now we have this is
their tactile feedback this airfield
watch so this is interesting because you
know if you you think about airplanes we
have one sensor for the air sometimes -
only the the fighters have to
so that so you said through the feathers
they you get the tactile sensing right
that's their tactile sensing so
interesting so when birds are flying
they have all the information of the air
in the airplane we only have two in the
airplane we use brute force so we create
in a laminar flow and then we prove the
profile into that to do the fly here we
sense the air we take advantage of that
so sure so they have a full so a bird
has a full model of the airflow going
all around them at all times
oh that's right that's why they can do
amazing things yeah they can even stop
and like gray de-iced all condition
which is a bad thing for an airplane but
a bird can go fly and create the stealth
emissions and land opera yeah and land
on the branch
oh and so those kind of things are so we
create I know that's I can't I can't
that's like they everyone always that
you know that question people are like
oh what kind of an animal would you want
to be and I always think like I want to
fly so bad but I also want to really go
into the depths of the ocean like yeah
octopus or squid or and don't be careful
what you wish for the next life besides
you know life is short this is just a
human experience but the top of the bird
food chain at the top of the ocean food
chain would be fine you'll survive so
here we create you know we put in a
profile and we put these feathers which
have sensors to detect that kind of
motion so we put in the water tunnel and
we see how we behave and we put it on
the in the air tunnel and so we can
detect the speed of the error by seeing
how they oscillate and here's a stall
condition and purpose we put it like
this to actually just say okay now we
can stop no flying landed so that is the
that was the project to do it smarter
airplanes with sensitive robotics yes if
you feel it then I can do a lot of
things in controller it's maybe worried
the airplane or just come to the right
we sure will be practical there are many
considerations right no this is
understanding how we can make now get it
back to AI so artificial intelligence
have these two currents as I mentioned
the top-down Wotton app so with
manipulation and with some more examples
we have shown that we can do a lot by
using
boughten app yeah and probably they have
been very complicated before now there
this approach will make it easier yeah
and it's not only about software that's
a very key part exactly we believe that
the eye is always software this is
what's called Bobby of AI yeah that name
was a thing coined by Rod Brooks again
and the idea is that if you have a body
you will be able to understand your
interaction with the world and allow you
to behave smartly or better more
efficiently more according to the
parameters where your where your inter
when your where we are living and then
you can take better decisions so that is
the approach to sensitive robotics and
that's how you know complicated problems
like handling these very small pieces we
have solved it without having to go
through these very complex modeling lots
of computation being used instead we
distributed computation on the sensing
and all along the body you know we
change the architecture at the control
level the arkad the computational level
but you know that will be a longer
conversation to have
yeah yeah holy cow but it's so
interesting going from the typical
classical thought process for people
with computer vision to sensitive
robotics because and now combining them
together right yeah all the techniques
of machine learning and things like that
we still use it but no what I will call
let's say brute force for computer
vision which we put tons of images and
we try it together we do the same thing
but you understand this type of signals
what patterns we can recognize this will
be that will be useful to control the
robot
so that's the end time okay and I see we
have the it's a big combination of both
the sensor development and figuring out
how to soft make soft contact on the
object the actual algorithms themselves
how to maintain contact I thought this
was really exciting because you
mentioned the slippage right right if
you you know right now I feel it kind of
slipping a little bit I'm like letting
the cup slip a little run my hand and so
how do you maintain that contact and
then if it's slipping
then you grab right and you know regrip
and so then you have to Center it regrip
it reduce the stress on it so that would
maybe if it's soft you need to reduce
the stress a little there's all these
nuances that are being built into this
right yeah as well so this is you know
the it basically changes a lot of things
in the way you approach this problem all
the ones you said they're physical but
then to the architectural level instead
of creating AI to have a plan for
everything we use what's called behavior
based architecture we create very simple
behaviors you can think as we create
reflexes as you go higher in the
hierarchy we create more complicated
behaviors and we modulate them so that's
another way to approach it that let
hasn't been that popular and like I'm
saying maybe know that populous because
now AI everyone talks about machine
learning and AI but this other area
which is as complex is kind of
forgetting or in the background right
now so behaviors combination behaviors
action selection all those things are
implemented in this architecture in
order to do this because what happens is
when you have tons of sensors normally
you have a camera and it has tons of
sensors there but you deal that like a
separate process okay that is the same
thing and it will give me something
there's a person there's a car there's
something when you have all the sensors
distribute now you can like separate
them but you need to organize tons of
sensors so
if you try to centralize everything
becomes a problem so we distribute the
computation and we distribute the local
behavior by creating this behaviors
again and then you put them all together
and so it emulates a lot how we believe
that the your neural system in the
people in every system in people is
distribute so we have a lot of
computation around our head but then as
you go to the local computation so yeah
that's that the extending the process
the computational processing to the
different locations rather than
centralizing all ok so let's run you
through a couple of these questions
especially since you're in this field I
think it's important to ask how often do
you think about and what do you think
about the ethics and the philosophy
behind AI there are many important
questions there right so I think you
know we have a lot of fear about what
can happen and then some there's some
applications that are purely based in
data that we need to control right that
we will be good to have some rules but
there is always this belief that if AI
is going to take over and it's gonna
like you know run our society and that
is I feel like no well understood here
yeah you know usually when you
understand things then you don't fear it
and smell it it's not you it's you know
when you see things like this when you
you know physically physical
applications of AI like robotics it's
very easy to see how behind we are so
when people go around saying how the
robots are gonna take over it's very
difficult to beliefs no one I happen is
that we're gonna have better tools for
us to use it yes that's true
but robots taking over the world that is
something that it's not there and we
show people in general we try to talk
more and understand what are the
principles behind to abort to avoid that
fear and then you know no make it a
complicated issue out of something that
we're very far away from there yes but
even today we have instances of there
being some sort of oops moments that we
have and we how do we kind of bacon
ethics and philosophy into programming
culture how do we give me a give me an
example of the oops moment just do to to
guide my okay you know even an oops
moment like telling a telling something
to be telling you telling you to get
maximize my my my route to get to a
place to another place and then you
decide and then you decide to go through
an area that might be restricted access
and it might hurt somebody or maximize
my monetary outcome and or her even as
far as to just point out the obvious one
with with BOTS
bot networks social social BOTS is we
have this oops moment now when we say
that oh it was probably not that great
of an idea to have all these
psychometric profiles that are then able
to be manipulated by by the way that we
push content that enrages their emotions
and stuff like that so anyway there's
different examples and but yeah right
but you know like make maybe a
distinction as I see it right so I think
if having control on how personal data
is share or is being used it's very
important but that is different from AI
so the gathering of the ADA it is if
it's legal no legal should we do it it's
something that we
they need to address and just there's
something I prefer to have my
information as private as possible it
took a long time for like you know my
friends forced me to get into Facebook
otherwise we would not be able to come
in the cave otherwise I won't have done
it right but I agreed so that is one
specific issue now the algorithms are
may I is know the reason of the problem
right is that there's data and we will
create algorithms maybe within call of
AI to exploit that and that is coming
from I guess always the possibility in
human nature trying to do something bad
with the technology that you have right
same as we have when we have nuclear
power we decide oh well you know a good
idea to give it to everyone right
because we might destroy the planet
right away so it's kind of like the same
thing right so yes there is this new
capability but no the capability of
solid that has been bad right we have
used radiation coming from nuclear
developments for other good things and
no no no we're not saying that that's
the recent ways that people sometimes
say it like all nuclear energy was the
technology is the ultimate question and
so then the idea of figuring out how to
bake together philosophy with
programming and stuff is it's an
interesting kind of future that I that I
foresee okay I wanted to say one thing I
think philosophy is very important to be
taught it's something we forgetting now
yeah we're giving a lot of information
and no philosophy yeah and that's what
usually causes all this problem yeah
exactly we had a little bit more of the
values baked into the foundation than we
wouldn't have so many of these problems
and there's a professor I saw that many
times yeah yeah okay how about and I
think you mentioned that to me when we
were hanging out yes yeah okay how about
we ask you with the proliferation of AI
and robotics across the world especially
mixing together sensitive robotics with
computer vision now it seems now we're
even closer to this these moments but
we're now seeing massive job
displacement but we're also seeing new
jobs be made across different fields but
it's kind of
the end of the repetitive work force the
service industry retail industry driving
all these kind of things what do you
think we should do to prevent some sort
of a big bow three train how do we
retrain but how do we prevent a a
class-based speciation where wealth one
end goes very wealthy one end goes what
do I do with my time now do I get
universal basic income what do I do so
many things about that so you know first
is like we have as humanity leaves this
process a number of times so it probably
will be very responsible as humanity to
accept that we go through this processes
and you know have rules about that sure
new technologies are gonna come I don't
think it's good for anyone trying to
forbid them or trying to like ban them
just because they're gonna display jobs
of course instead I think it's like as a
humanity say okay where these new
technologies gonna do this we should
leader create a commission or create
something that allow us to do this
transition many you know many creative
things we might develop to deal with
this you know if someone is like sixty
years old and it's been doing like you
know always like get like harvesting
strawberries we if we know that it can
not do anything else we should be
sensitive and say well you know maybe
create a program for either retraining
or some sort of welfare I'm not know
necessarily this because yes just having
welfare for no reason is not a good idea
but if we ask him anything well now
we're ringing this new thing that makes
us more efficient there are many ways to
do tax as many public policies to deal
with this thing so I think what's
important is to say yes that is a
transition and as we as we as humanity
recognize and this time we're gonna face
it as opposed to that the mark and do it
that you know when overarching idea
what's happening is helpful because the
business is not gonna do that because
the business trying to to work with new
technologies to be productive and that's
what they're trying to do they're been
honest about it the people being
displaced sometimes the people who have
no
so we do need to protect them in some
way because otherwise then we're just
creating a crisis for no reason
yeah and it's a really important one to
address along the way this transition
with AI and robotics how do we do it
smoothly correct and safely
okay how about quick quick last question
let's ask you what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world for me
I love sunsets in the beach when you get
to see you know like how small we are
saying this big planning coming out that
we sometimes say oh you know sorry the
big this week's piece of matter the the
Sun coming out or coming down and well
we're very small but we get to enjoy all
these like very beautiful things created
by this humongous process like food
kitchen that's happening in the Sun yeah
but for you it was reflected to your
sensors and then you as a person feel
like oh I'm so small but this is like
it's so amazing and stimulating my
sensing and that's one of the those
moments that I like to enjoy and like
that well you know in many areas in my
patients or especially they call it like
it like enjoy the moment so yeah just
this to be like most beautiful because I
do that very often or I used to do this
when I was at school you know sitting
and the child's River and boss looking
over what this is happening and he
always was like you know a moment of
peace to to get you have of the problems
that are you know and be when you take a
bigger perspective there's no that big
at all right you get to see where you
are so I love that answer we love
sunsets as well and sunrise they're so
important they're so important okay what
a good show I'm glad we did it
yeah it's outstanding it were thank you
thank you joining me
yes as a blast we learned so much today
sensitive robotics importance of this in
the future our cordless yeah yeah and
we're really excited to you know to down
the line when maybe we can bring some of
the sample these samples on the show
play around with it and we'll go into
more detail once you guys are ready to
share about what is going on well thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you if you had a good time
give the content to share share with
other people give them excited about AI
and robotics and all these different
ways that we're sensing and subscribe
join us join us on patreon we need to
sustain the studio sustain our project
and keep inspiring people around the
world so join us there and we will see
you guys soon thanks to our producing
partner Ron Vargas much love everyone
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]